Today, as Americans, we grieve the brutal murder,...
...a horrific massacre of dozens of innocent people.
We pray for their families who are grasping for answers with broken hearts.
We stand with the people of Orlando,...
...who have endured a terrible attack on their city.
Although it's still early in the investigation,...
...we know enough to say that this was an act of terror and an act of hate,...
...and as Americans, we are united in grief, in outrage,...
...and in resolve to defend our people.
As we go together, we will draw inspiration from heroic and selfless acts:...
...friends who helped friends, took care of each other and saved lives.
In the face of hate and violence, we will love one another.
We will not give in to fear or turn against each other.
Instead, we will stand united as Americans,...
...to protect our people and defend our nation,...
...and to take action against those who threaten us.